[Applause]
hey every guy's welcome hey every guys
hey everyone welcome back to potato mode
the show where we take the most
beautiful games we know and drag him
through the mud we take their graphics
and just turn them into mush
my name is Joey I'm joined here by Kelly
Peggy hello and this week in case you
guys haven't noticed we are playing
Skyrim thank you - I don't know how many
people actually sent in a request to see
the game potato fide but here we are we
finally got around to it I'm very
excited I think I was one of the people
who requested it that convinced me to do
it to begin with but we have the game
running at 1080p right now you can walk
around killer I'm on I got you got me on
this cool platform yeah a lot of jumping
but we also have a couple of mods
installed right now if you're not
familiar with ENB series it's a open
source mod that allows people to put
their own shaders and lighting changes
and everything there's a lot to explain
with that so I won't go into full detail
but I'll put a link into the description
below if you want to read more about the
ENB series this game is looking pretty
good right now yeah for what
seven-year-old game is gonna be 7 this
year yeah almost seven year old game
it's looking pretty fine I watch I got
Rifton because Rifton is my favorite
place that I ever go to in Skyrim yeah
where's this this is the sewer basically
there's all sorts of cool stuff going on
around here there's all sorts of stuff
down here York and Dam Rifton rifton's
not a great place it's not a great place
to live
yeah I feel like there's there's so many
places in Skyrim that I feel like we
could maybe give some people advice
about where to go
maybe it's like a travel guide if you
will I think you're right Joey this is
on the way to the Thieves Guild this is
where you go if you want to oh my god by
the way your level 1 well that didn't go
so well well ok so I think we can say
pretty confidently
not to go to Rifton when hell is
interesting it's the oldest city in
Skyrim which means it has a lot of
traditions that are great
basically one area for the Dark Elves to
live and then one area for the Nords and
high elves to live Kali do you have any
recommendations for places we can visit
in hell we got well this is cool
cemetery so would not recommend going
here unless you want to be involved in a
murder investigation
that's good I've started the quest and
it maybe not be a welcoming place as you
can see from all the blood but at the
very least it looks nice well I think
we've we've seen a good amount of went
home looking nice mm-hmm I think it
deserves a little potato vacation so
here we have the Nexus mod manager the
number one mod manager in all of gaming
brought to you by GameSpot we have one
mod here and that's all we're gonna need
right here it's called quite fittingly
terrible textures not just terrible
textures but Terrill textures for a weak
computer I was about to say it's gonna
be really weird because you know what I
just realized I didn't I didn't take out
the ENB mod which means that everything
is still like spectacular like bright
and glossy but I got more than a couple
of things going on all right so these
doors were I think just normal like iron
or Thor's and now they're like the gates
of hell this is the Palace of the Kings
apparently we've always gone from the
highest settings and then dropped it
down to the low settings and then went
and did like all the crazy stuff when
you combine the two highest and lowest
settings at the same time this is kind
of what you get oh my god I even know
how to describe it but I feel like I'm
in some weird purgatory where I'm
halfway between real life you know like
in Harry Potter where he's on the Kings
Cross station yeah yeah and it all looks
like white and bright but you can still
tell where you are we're like halfway in
there that's where that's where we're at
right now
I am so disturbed looking a glassy this
meat is let's go let's go to winter
holds oh I can't faster I believe the
first guys happy to see you lovin
where were we supposed to go here I
wanted to go to the college I think
that's it but I don't know how to get
there anymore oh we can't go we can't
enter the college yet man it's really
hard to track what I have and have not
unlocked in this guy I'm pretty sure
this a fall has nothing on goal
locations just locations well here you
have it the college come visit the
college of winterhold it's great 3 out
of 5 stars
ok so this one this is the muddiest this
games looked so far we don't have any
goals nothing we just literally woke up
from like a 50-year coma and went on our
merry way
oh he's definitely gonna see you oh yeah
who puts a cabbage in the oven ok well
we have that that's all we know you know
sometimes you just gotta yell let's
check out more assault - it's a very big
city in skyrim things to do number one
number one go to the catacombs get lost
good guy okay the fire still looks real
good actually so we're trying to wrap my
head around everything that's going on
right now
[Music]
this doesn't oh my god doesn't even have
individual ribs really go first person
here oh my god I think the balloon
animal analogies is pretty apt look at
these like office building stairs this
is the hall of the Dead it doesn't look
so grand right it's not very death
fully if you ask me to fault Greece aha
oh wait we are not going to fall crease
all right well maybe Plan B let's go to
Warsaw
oh my god okay well this is I feel like
it's becoming a little bit normal what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go into the
settings of the Nvidia profile inspector
if you're seeing the show before you
know what I'm talking about so we're
gonna do that right now
this looks pretty muddy okay it's pretty
bad yeah so what we also what I did in
attempt did you see it it like moved
there we go I think those are well
basically I turned off the the ENB mod
so you can see by the decrease in like
lighting quality I also attempted to do
the trick with the Nvidia profile
inspector which is turning all the
textures down to like nothing but
apparently the people are unaffected by
it are they on a different they're on a
different wavelength they're a different
point of existence okay so the shadows
on the people have been affected like
the models and everything are fine and I
can't figure out how to change that
that's gonna be a problem maybe we
should start a new game you know what we
should start a new game I think that's
it okay the horse is pretty he's looking
good do you see that boy he looks all he
looks extra chubby he's no one gonna
point out the fact that all the trees
razor blades anyone okay okay let's
speed this up a little
I'm spud keep it a theme with the show
right I'm waiting for the dragon to show
up this will be the big entrance
actually can I do one thing before we go
any further but maybe right before the
dragon comes out oh my god I think we
are in business I think we're in
business - yes hard work sometimes pays
off guys never never give up on your
dreams never give up always be striving
for something greater oh my god I've
never been happier that's is forgot
about that
ghost bud oh this is gonna be an
interesting angle I kinda want to go
back to the character select screen I
think just a little bit Hey looks pretty
good
he looks actually a little bit more
menacing just a shadow just darkness all
over there we go okay just gonna go in
here because I know he'll he'll come
right to us
I don't look at me like scarier than the
dragon he stills people's well that's a
good thing right Oh usually when we get
to this point all the pupils are gone if
you give them the side eye a little bit
oh I got the blood on my skinny is gonna
get real blocking you're gonna be able
to see anything
you know Heligan of all the sites and
Skyrim's not the most compelling
I think we should go somewhere else
yeah now that we can actually mess up
people's faces I want to see Lydia again
oh my god it's like they're wearing
someone else's skin oh this is not Lydia
this is this is a robot with Lydia's
face on it I know I can't even find my
way around cuz I'm in this like weird
world that oh my god hide ruin books oh
no I don't wait someone forgot to finish
it apparently steel I like that one page
that was different this one I want to
see some horses okay well just fast
travel to a stable and steal a horse and
ride into the whatever the sunset
currently looks like
where are you beauties well now you have
a bounty on this what's wrong well he
doesn't even move like a horse should
all right climbing a mountain sounds
like a perfect idea
potato mode or none this never gets old
it really does you're fine you're fine I
don't exist in this world well I think
that's about the best place we could end
this this is where I live now oh my
goodness well anyway thank you guys so
much for watching if you have a
suggestion for another game that you
want to see potato five just leave in
the comments below it can hit us up on
Twitter and we will see you next Friday
there we go just a little short show
that I learned from the fallout 4
episode that we did I think the lack of
like any sort of gesticulation a hip
who's a little bit more play